day four and more came out the street so
packed in places it was hard to move
estimates put the numbers at over a
million people across the entire country
this fractured society defined by
sectarian allegiances but now people
united under the Lebanese flag while
pointing the finger at their politicians
the leaders are liars they promised us
reforms and change but they did nothing
they only benefited themselves and
didn't do anything for the people
President Michelle Woon promised reform
but he didn't do anything all liars
it's been 30 years of this these
protests are the result of years of
political infighting and political
stalemate people accuse their leaders of
being too preoccupied with their own
gains resulting in an economy on its
deathbed Lebanon's debt is the third
highest in the world
attempts to tax the people increasingly
poor have hit a nerve ingrained
corruption they tell us has made life
impossible
we can't we have to be the man and the
woman the wife they have to work in
order to pay to live in a good way stay
like this the government must do
something for the people the people are
chanting the people want the fall of the
regime they've been calling for a
revolution they've been singing songs
all night long there may be a real party
atmosphere here but there are real
serious issues at stake there are
reports that the government has reached
a deal including reforming the
electricity sector injecting cash to
curb public debt and cutting politician
salaries it will go to a vote on Monday
we don't want them nor their reforms we
want to change their faces we are sick
of their faces we weren't educated
people to change the country and we
don't want them to be affiliated to any
party Lebanon has never seen anything
like this the 72-hour deadline imposed
by the prime minister Saud Hadid II
expires on Monday
most people have told us that the
reforms are not enough they will stay on
the streets until the government resigns
but the question is the government
refuses to go will they let hundreds of
thousands of people continue to call for
its fall Stephanie Decker al Jazeera
Beirut